for years the libs told conservatives
that if we don't like the way that they
censor us on big tech platforms that we
should build our own build your own
twitter build your own facebook build
your own google
the suggestion is absurd
maybe in the very earliest days of
social media there was room for
competition
remember myspace live journal xanga
friendster lots of other sites those
days are over they've been over for a
long time eventually a handful of
platforms reached a critical mass and
ensconced themselves in power
and they formed cozy relationships with
the federal government and they
exploited legal liability protections
and they even outright defrauded the
user base that gave them the critical
mass in the first place with the
understanding that they would be able to
see and post whatever they wanted to
then the big tech companies pulled the
rug out it is simply not possible to
build our own twitter it hasn't been for
years and leftists know it which is why
they keep making the suggestion
conservatives could try to wield the
government to bring these massive
corporations into line but that's very
difficult if not impossible and lots of
conservatives don't have the stomach for
it and even those of us who do have the
stomach for it don't have any real
political power in a system dominated
almost entirely by the left
but it turns out there's a third option
beyond build your own twitter and break
twitter
and that is
buy twitter
buy twitter which is what elon musk is
apparently willing to do spending more
than 41
billion dollars right now on offer and
why is he doing it
my
strong intuitive sense is that uh having
a public platform that is maximally
trusted
um and and and and
broadly inclusive
um
is extremely important
to the future of civilization but you've
described yourself i don't care about
the economics at all
okay that's that's core to here bingo
republics govern through speech in the
public square
twitter makes up a huge portion of the
public square
and twitter is keeping lots of americans
out of the public square including
really prominent ones including donald
trump right including the duly elected
sitting president when they took him out
which means as a practical matter that
right now we are no longer living in a
functioning republic
so elon musk is going to mount a hostile
takeover
to take it back and what happens if that
takeover attempt doesn't work
okay so so you don't like to lose if in
this case you are not successful in you
know the board
does not accept your offer you've said
you won't go higher is there a plan b
there is
i i think we i think we would like to
hear a little bit about plan b
for it for another time i think
another time yeah all right
i
love it so much
i don't think i'm going to tell you my
plan b elon of course could have
anything up his sleeve he's currently
got more than nine percent of the
company up his sleeve meaning that he
could sell all of it and tank the stock
or he might have something even more
creative planned or or it might all just
be a giant troll
to expose the hideous corruption at
twitter and throughout silicon valley
either way
it is the most hopeful moment for
conservatives that we have had in
politics since election night 2016.
right now head on over to
missonandmain.com use promo code knolls
just the other day i was packing for a
trip down to the beach and i open up my
closet where does my eye go right to
goes right to one of my absolute
favorite polo shirts from misson in
maine what do i love so much about this
shirt one
number one it looks phenomenal the style
is just really crisp and clean and
sophisticated looking but two i am of
italian descent it means i have a
penchant for perspiring okay this is not
great with a lot of different shirt
companies mizzen and main because it's
that performance athletic material with
that great classic style it means i
don't need to worry about sweating
through my shirt they've got all sorts
of stuff they've obviously got their
great oxford shirts they've got
you know dress shirts everything you can
skip the dry cleaner i really love those
performance polos in particular right
now
whether you're working from the golf
course or taking conference calls in the
courtyard we've got some really great
news right now if you go to
missoninmain.com use promo code
knowledge you get 35 off any regular
price order of 125 bucks or more that's
35 bucks off when you go to
m-i-z-z-e-n-a-n-d-m-a-i-n-dot-com use
promo code knowles
did you like that clip good i'm glad
ring that bell
subscribe
get the notifications head on over to
apple podcast but if i stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you